la route qui met la vie
entre dessus de la mer
il m'avait pris
ce bourg est mon mari
paris -
e
parle moi de toi
tu es la bouche suit la voie par mois
comme si le monde vous n'existez pas
tu vois ça c'est le début d'une chanson
je suis en train d'écrire pour le
prochain prochain petit ça va être un
grand puis comme d'habitude je reviens
un brignogan pour pour travailler
rires
brignogan c'est autant l'okano laisser
mes souvenirs d'enfance brignogan c'est
mon ami et mon adolescence avec d'abord
mes racines du côté de mon père puisque
mon père est né à peu près 2 km
dissidents devant ces rochers et c'est
aussi dans ces roches et que tu as eu le
déclic lieu le déclic avec pierre
brasseur puisqu'il ya tourné ici les
extérieurs de boto l'île d'amour une de
breivik et c'est là que j'ai rencontré
et les brasseurs ça a été mon père noël
puisque il m'a ramené dans sa hotte à
paris et c'est comme ça que tout a
commencé
il faut dire que tout me préparer un peu
à ça c'est à dire que dans mon enfance
j'ai été entouré de deux femmes des
jeunes filles c'est à dire ma mère qui
était directrice d'école ma mamie kim
élevé pendant que ma mère faisait la
classe juste à côté d'ailleurs ce qui
fait que je pouvais pas m'échapper très
loin et les élèves de ma mère qui va
avoir la jeudi certificat d'études et
qui jouent avec moi comme avec un une
sorte de petit prince un petit peu
intouchable image en profitait alors je
me réfugiais le temps qui le temps où je
pouvais partir dans la nature
allez parler aux oiseaux ont violé les
corbeaux quand il chantait faux je me
réfugier dans les bras d'une troisième
femme qui était la solitude et c'est là
que tout a démarré finalement ma
solitude à moi c'était quelque chose de
grandiose c'était une conquête
permanente de l'espace entre ce ciel qui
étaient parfois bleu mais plus souvent
gris cette mère qui était parfois grise
et plus souvent verte qui est l élément
qui me manquait
il tenait de la pure de ma venue
sai par débat
hbo a surgi de
ton père
un jeu
et
cl
darrigand
à temps
aussi le
je t'appelle
les temps
com
deschamps
rageant
et moi
qui suit
dans le cas
et pourtant
enfants
petit
m
dans ça
quand je dis que j'étais un solitaire
c'est c'est un petit peu faux car dans
la solitude de la bretagne sur les parmi
les vieilles pierres
il ya toujours tout un peuple le
korrigan de le fait que les cuissons qui
était un personnage de mon enfance j'ai
toujours aimé le rêver du moyen-âge de
château peuple et dire peut-être de
bondy aussi il en est pas ici tout était
propice à vos rêves d'imagination et sur
la dune où on se retrouver entre copains
mais c'était peut-être ses copains là
qui sont devenus les les korrigans de ma
vie parce que c'est qu'on était aussi
mon premier public
et puis il ya eu la bonne quand une
femme qui est aussi un personnage qui la
cousine de mon père que j'ai toujours
appelé tante yvonne et qui tient le café
tabac sur la place et c'est là que
j'allais me réfugier quand mes parents
disent c'est pas un métier et c'est lui
moi je me croyais dur comme fer santé
van uhm a remonté le moral dans un port
situé 7 qui j'ai un peu jeudi mongol a
changé bien beau mais il faut y aurait
eu si tu réussis par qu'est ce que tu
vas faire ça va mal guebbas y avait
aussi pas il fera comme gbagbo
j'ai été très dur très dur alors elle a
persévéré il a réussi
grand-mère les verts
nos chemises eau la voile point de la
remise le ch a fait le gros dos sur la
trt auprès du ce
qu'elle est belle ma bretagne quand elle
pleut
et
papa nous quand m
dès les gens
de trésors enfouis sous la halle
maman cacher quelques pièces et des
draps
que les bains
la bretagne
et la petite fille de l'école
je crois
clavel roujan
c'est jamais vous et lui dit
samura
qu'elle est belle
ma bru demain
quand elle peut
et je rêvais
de la gare
des bûcherons des bus rome
le petit bois
le chez nous
assignée
qu'elle est belle
la bretonne
tous les marins
qui se souvient
des barques qui gêne
ont une envie
de la mer quand même
au fond des yeux
que les belles
ma bretagne quand elle pleut
m
les femmes vont graviter autour de moi
et puis quand elle les épaules je vous
charge et une gravité autour d'elle
c'est important oui parce que la qualité
première chez la femme c'est la
sécurisation
les femmes disent toujours que ce sont
elles qui en se mariant cherchent la
sécurité en fait c'est pas vrai sens
beaucoup plus fortement et pour moi
j'aurais été un grand vin de rambus donc
puis je pense pas que ça encore
longtemps donc à certains moments de la
vie quand tout va bien et qu'on a envie
de partager les joies ou quand il tout
va mal c'est pour moi il n'y a rien de
mieux qu'une femme
si les chats de temps en temps aussi
c'est bien il est bon les femmes on peut
leur parler on peut leur dire des choses
et elles répondent va ya ça sent bon ici
c'est du caca phase de santé actuel le
bélarus à san jose les femmes qu'on
épouse il ya celle que quand on épouse
pas puis à celles qui restent ont
toujours des grands mères qui le sont
depuis depuis toujours il ya ma femme à
une mamie qui est un personnage en plus
typiquement breton qui est solide comme
le granit et tendre comme la vague
c'est un personnage très fort qui est
avec une
une grosse boîte tout comme quand même
mis à quoi oui puisque tu l'invités si
j'avais à choisir l'époque je vivais
j'aurais certainement choisi le mcs
moyen-âge c'est pour de multiples
raisons d'abord parce que pourrait se
déplacer à cheval n'avait qu'une seule
guitare sans avoir besoin d'un prêt sera
chaud de le garder de l'argent sur soi
on allège aurait été de château en
château ou de village en village
j'aurais été à la rencontre des gens
j'aurais dû chanter dans des conditions
superbes dire qu' on aurait bien manger
on aurait bien vu ça c'est important
aussi
et puis j'aurais eu peut-être davantage
de conquérir la fille du châtelain la
fermière du coin c'était bon qui
j'aurais tout fait vous à cela
actuellement désespérance personnel
c'est de pouvoir m'arrêter de faire le
métier en tant que show-business assez
vite je veux pas du tout envie de me
retirer comme un ermite qui
j'aimerais bien souffler un peu
pas
tha
pour moi
puis
vous
marquant
là
je suis là
on nettoie